you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens hey everybody we are live
from gamespot's co-op stage here at e3
2016 and we got something a little
special for you right now joining us on
the couch is Isaac Taurus designer iron
galaxy working on the new killer
instinct and today he's gonna he's come
on stage to show us a little bit of
general wrong which was announced
yesterday and released yesterday yep so
thanks for coming man yeah i'm at no
problem and general rahm is available to
everybody right now this week so if you
have killer instaling just download it
right now if you don't free to play for
you to play general rahm as well oh very
smart of you guys school joining us as
well as nick and if you guys don't know
nick and i are both huge fighting game
fans as well as killer instinct fans so
figured we hate reached out to you even
get you on here and you know kind of
give us the rundown so this is a new
character people want to download all
that information tell us about wrong
yeah so let's just get right to it so
rom is a grapple character okay hi he's
the the games like most truest form of a
grapple character okay he has only one
opener one linker but he has really good
grab range okay oh you're ready in a
second once we load into game this
character is insane he does really good
damage he has this cruel that he can use
because he's general rahm right we're
watching this intro right now he has the
Cronus around him he can't eat that
krill and put it on the opponent I'll
show you in a second one okay what sort
of options that he has just spray krill
on people so it's kind of an interesting
thing because this is a really big
character but he actually I don't see
that quite a bit of mobility so he has a
pretty good walk speed he has really
good range like that says heavy punch
right there wow it's gonna be one of
your go-to attacks for general Rahm just
gonna like sliced people from kind of
mid-range he has the one of the fastest
medium punches in the game to fully
framed that is definitely a match for
how huge of a character he exactly so
you're gonna kind of be using this
attack to like really bully people it's
really good attack and then his specials
so his opener he has decimation and
that's this attack right here so the
lite version is
not something that you want to throw out
too often because it's really unsafe
okay but the medium version is pretty
safe to do it's like minus three if you
care about frame data and there anybody
watching that's not into fighting game
yeah unsafe means that it leaves you
open exactly it's Little Rock you're
gonna get hit yeah so you want you kind
of want to use the heavy version you can
use that in like a neutral game so use
the heavy version from like mid-range
his other special move is that command
grab I told you about decimation his
quarter circle back punch he grabs you
throwing up to a demands rough this move
has really good range so stay still for
a second sure she'd be like right here
and i can still a be my gosh really good
range for that light version the attack
so you're raising a lot very scary
character to get in on oh yeah for sure
that's the lite version what about mid
and heavy what is omitted heavy
basically they have less range but they
deal more damage so I'll do the heavy
version has a little bit less range I'll
die just like start stomping on your
face oh man nice i noticed earlier when
i was over checking it out that the
shadow version he's double stumps and
then is that one more like i could give
you one yeah you want to show them the
sure so here's the shadow version of the
attack now this move right here is the
fast I love it move in the entire game
it starts in one frame wow so he can
punish stuff that others other
characters can't punish which is really
crazy so you can do something like
that's how you make a grappler yes like
this yeah kickham so yeah you can win
kick me and that that's honestly
punished so you have to approach this
character very differently when you're
fighting general Rahm because he can
just mess you up really scary with meter
oh yeah so he also has uh you can get
full screen I'll show you the krill rush
attack okay so basically it's a really
good attack to get through projectile so
if you want to throw projector at me I
can get through patron else so it has
limited range obviously but you can
react to people doing a projectile get
in on them and it doesn't grab this leap
like cotton or ramen in advantage and he
can just like start he can grab you he
can like do an attack so what's happened
in the migra what does it cruller so
right now you have the krill swarm on
you and basically you're taking damage
for 10 seconds so I'll do it again so
I'm going to grab you once that swarm is
on you your take lowdown exciting Wow
so he's a really really tricky grapple
character cuz he doesn't even have to be
attacking you right now and he's still
hurting you and even if I hit you it
doesn't get off it does so if you
actually hit me it goes away okay okay
yeah so that's exactly what you want to
do you want to hit general Rahm get rid
of it but the thing is to hit them you
have to kind of get up close so we can
exactly or any grab you and you're
getting get stabbed yeah his other
attack is called emergence next quarter
circle forward kick and he kind of
summons the krill so that version
actually is low and vulnerable this
version right here that's the medium
punch that one is high and vulnerable
and then the heavy aubergine is fully
strike and vulnerable it has a slower
start up though but this is a really
good anti-earth good way for keeping
people off you yeah exactly so if
somebody is jumping in on you do that
not only do you answered him you're
actually poisoning them as well with the
krill okay so it's a really good attack
ginga had his arms cross didn't really
care all that much about the krill well
I'm out of dying yeah he died moments
later yeah so we can do another quick
rematch right here alright let's go man
it's been great first of all you guys
picking up the game oh yeah I was super
worried when you know the announcement
of a double helix going over to Amazon
was like no like they built this great
game what's going to happen and then you
guys got the property and I was really
excited because you guys are doing a lot
of work on fighting games I mean third
strike online edition model vs capcom
darkstalkers made have sold better and
man I you know just really happy that
you guys are taking a part of this and
so how did you hear about getting killer
instincts also I mean that story is kind
of interesting it's it's a story of a
lot of just like rumors and speculation
uh there's obviously people in the
company that kind of knew that it was a
thing but it was really hot hush but
then you know I was talking to Adam hard
and he's he just kept insisting that I
played the game and I had played the
game at evo I really enjoyed the game at
evo and I was like man this game is also
i'm really glad to see killer instinct
is back and but he's like no really play
it like I was like yeah you should
really play it but if you know what's
good for you you should play it and then
all of a sudden I heard the announcement
that we were gonna be working on it I
was like oh that makes so much sense and
I mean I bought xbox one to play the
game I really delve really really far
into the game just to learn all the
mechanics and it's been an awesome ride
but what's an extra bonus to it isn't so
not only you get to work on like one of
this thus most Titanic classic fighting
game franchises with killer instinct but
then also now you're throwing all sorts
of crazy stuff in here like rash oh yeah
wrong ya know in season three we got
rash we got arbiter from Halo right we
got general Rahm it's absolutely insane
waiting on Chris copper tease come on ah
yeah that would be the few add conquer
to this game yeah I will lose it I
promise to you I got a question yeah I
will question about Ram yeah rom sorry
yeah what is his instinct new Ivan
though his instinct is really cool so
I'll summon it basically it's called the
the krill storm he's somewhat ill
exactly so it kind of covers up rom so
you can barely see them and basically
you're taking potential damage that
entire time oh no I'm gonna do an opener
on you okay and then I'm gonna do my
under level for ender after a one-chance
break and I'm getting all this damage
that's like fifty four percent break Oh
chance oh yeah right there not really
really really good oh we were playing a
bit earlier and I was playing against um
that one pro player yeah yeah and he
absolutely just he picked this character
that just came out and I picked my main
and just got absolutely obliterated but
that was one thing I learned really
early on is he does a scary amount of
dahlia very quickly and he has a lot of
different properties suited we still
haven't even shown so one thing that he
has is the curl shield and you do that
by pressing all three punches and
basically I can absorb beside your deck
tiles I can go for potential damage
exactly and it does full damage of
potential damage on you you don't take
any actual damage well you take the full
amount of potential damage ok that's a
dessin interesting trade-off yeah
exactly and you can absorb an infant
dolls hey you can go absorb only one
physical attack ah but it also soldier
yeah yeah you sure Julie otro DDLJ
biggest one you can do I here you go oh
so much stabbing and kicking and all
yelling no general Rahm really likes
using history that sword yeah let's see
if I go up it gives it there we go I'll
fight you to even practicing something I
can tell ya go
it you want to just style for a second
you know of some of his convos yeah
that's totally fine and then before we
get to the end which we've only got
about like got like six more minutes
yeah I love for you guys to throw down
cuz you know Nick's oh we got ten
minutes working we got seven it's okay
yeah we leave I definitely want to see
you guys go head-to-head cuz you work on
the game yeah and Nick plays ki
lightning religiously much yeah way too
much like I'm trying to get him to play
overwatch like anything else he's like
yeah I was gonna play over the weekend
then I just play ki all weekend yeah so
do you and I know how many little short
some drama do it combos here yes I like
this red oh yeah there's some stuff
about rom that we haven't even shown you
that he can do he has a lot of new
mechanics of the game one of which is an
OTG so that an OTG is awesome I'm bed
right you off the ground so tusk has a
similar move where he can jump with his
sword Schiavi a skewer yeah so general
Rahm has a thing where he can stomp you
repeatedly just like just man really yes
really what you do in that earlier and
yeah he'll throw them down and then just
stop me so it's really deceptive you
think like all right okay he just like
rush me down I got like a second of a
breather while I'm on the ground as I'm
waking up to think about what imma do
then it's like oh [ __ ] no I don't yeah
exactly and obviously they're all fully
breakable so i can i can show you guys
right now go for it so this is the
medium version and you can leave that
open them so obviously my connection
with mama haha I mean less time and he
has another version now this is the
version that's gonna really freak people
out so I'm gonna knock him down and he
flips on right back up alright lets out
that's really been recaptured into a
combo so what I can do and obviously he
was able to break that with lights so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna do this
oh let me just try it out one more time
and I'm gonna go straight into grab oh
right so the whole mix up there is like
what is he gonna do is he gonna go for a
grab or is he gonna jump is he gonna
just like throw me this character is
terrifying exactly there's a ton of
damage super fast and you're not even
safe when you're on the ground yeah and
he has crazy jump distance too so stand
a little bit barbato so his jumping
heavy kick is insane so you can stop
right now alright i can probably hit him
with his jumping Evie kick from right
here oh that's absolutely insane
distance yeah so this character he's
really good with the only real
projectiles you can use that to kind
get in poison your opponent and you kind
of want to just mess with them and just
bully him around why not like poke him
like this a little bit all those bells
really good I just wanted hit you that
yeah no I jump at me so one thing is
that's one of the best an tires in the
game so don't cite them with a heavy
punch which is about nine frames and
then might as well just do this because
it's gonna pull ya him as well right
using an extra dammit right hey good Nix
Nix figured it out annuals ah I debate
the break there so with this character
he's kind of a little bit about patience
I was a good anti-air there he's a
little bit about patience kind of
picking your right moment but he's also
about really bullying people and making
them scared to do anything oh he just
grabbed them and that's the way I felt
yeah when I was playing against him
earlier like II you don't want to get in
on him because he's gonna grab you yeah
but if he opens an icon we just did a
ton of damage and you're trying to sit
there and process the sheer amount of
pain you just received and then he's
stomping on you flipping you actually
it's never over very very very I tried
to deal with I don't know what I'm doing
anymore who would you say is his hardest
counter right now uh I find that he
maybe I might not be right about this ah
but I really found it difficult to fight
against like Glacia seeeeee I just felt
like glacis was just really keeping him
out it was hard to kind of get in like I
used my shield but if a glace players
like really smart I think he can keep
general Rahm just kind of really far
away from him ok cool and who does he
crush who does he count her like super I
think he can crush anybody who have
anyone know if you have lowes like a
week spirit I think we're if you can get
intimidated he can just destroy
everybody i see counters a week fight
exaggerated heard it here first you can
pick your sadira player right no no your
play yeah yeah I use uh fulgor will a
secret door yeah yeah I picked up Jay
goes okay that's cool yeah I love I'm
gonna go you only oh you're gonna play
wrong yeah are you hard cool alright
next gonna give them the full girl right
I'm not playing on the controller how
long also the excuses are already are
you coming out yeah if you are familiar
with the smash community called
sounds are coming out right here on
gamespot scoff stage live for me to hear
about to have a showdown you have the
masters of killer today we've got Nick
from ScrewAttack versus Isaac from iron
galaxy so I don't know you you're like
the worst position here because everyone
will just give you crap because you work
on the game feel is very true i mean
i'll give nick crabber if he loses but
you know so we'll craig hofstede you
know which is there we go Walt sweet and
Nick if you lose everyone should tweet
at the nervous Nick and just blew him
all right all right so we have a ki
character vs Gears of War care did you
ever think you would say that in your
life I know it's insane and he's playing
on a halo stage yeah i right it's just
awesome with this week fo k yeah that
was so clearly not inspired by Zangief
at all that Joanie crossing was talking
about yeah where's your lariat oh here
you go Nick what is on give me a sec
haha there's no mercy for the weak oh
nice he's countering your week I was
gonna want your idea shiny oh there you
go get in there that overhead oh so pain
hey didn't this character like just come
out first came out the new character
Nick oh I guess that is one advantage
that you don't know nao like oh come on
yeah [ __ ] was right you know I was
right hahahaha oh my god don't ain't
this Carol rom is just super fun to play
and I'm just gonna bully you right now
I'm just gonna play oh I'm gonna jump in
on you look at it all right well I got
this attack right here I'll just let
this lead your neo you honorable would
do that yeah well there we go Nick got
the first light bar so oh wow and I'm
gonna be over here agra okay oh oh it's
gonna absorb it Nick's got lasers for
days alright that was nice I respect
that o Dick's not respecting your krill
though
little extra paint we go he's coming
back now you were just letting him win
right Nick that's always good Joe happy
oh no I forgot already wow it's so dark
oh that was good iris you don't need to
see to just mash an uppercut oh he's
just mashing oh no oh no Vic come on
Isaac you were love you merely adopted
the dark i was born in it oh no oh no
such an intense matches get away we go
that was good all right you take a
behind all right we got time for like
one more game all right on this out
should I everybody tweet that Isaac
which is at Del R at dlr I a pronounced
their right to everybody gets it wrong
no ry'ac your what I know this cuz I
heard somebody pronounced today okay I
world coppers oh I see you know
somewhere Keats is crying cuz you just
lost on stage I know can I have his job
give yeah he's gonna round these buffs
is that how you guys hire people you
just have to like go through the
gauntlet and if you beat them then you
get their job oh yeah that's how I
that's exactly how it worked okay
perfect oh that was nice you baited me
all right oh I meant about smashing Nick
receiving a boner sure this guy is good
get in my corner oh man hockey now okay
all right sit down please this is a
whole little heresy I mean I'm not
kidding [ __ ] really good I am really
okay I keep forgetting about that move
alright well he's gonna teach it to you
over and over again here we go this is
gonna hurt one time in my life are the
one time you go for a heavy linker guy
that did so much yeah this is why
general Rahm is really scary because all
i did was activated instinct than he
already lost his life for so the match
was even though i noticed when he's an
instinct he does he only deals potential
damage yep okay and but you can end it
and get that damage here exactly i could
and one of the best centers to do in
that situation is really a bunch is
quarter Bert circle back lunch because
that's his damage enter and it's a
really long animation awesome see Nick
I'm distracting him with talk yeah don't
you like that I could have picked up a
song no oh no you lose that oh oh sure
that's not allowed that's a glacial bet
it's not looking too good rob thicke oh
he breaks out good Oh Nick I want to do
so only one that hi fancy going for a
hike only one way I want to finish this
there's only what it's trying to choose
your death no no oh you got your you all
right that's good games I'm great night
love well Isaac thanks so much for
coming on going off general Rahm again
guys is available right now if you guys
want in this free exactly 3 download the
game redeploy a general Rahm let us know
what you think he's pretty awesome cool
and if you're out here at e3 you might
catch us later they're sure they're
gonna be running it back over at
Microsoft's killer headache set up I'll
do it thank you guys so much joining us
for gamespot co-op stage here d 3 2016
coming up next we have what the best and
worst of e3 so people shouldn't yell at
me yell at me on stage so we'll see you
guys in a second
you